[Musique]
après Madagascar le Bich rugby s'est
installé ce 22 décembre du côté de la
plage de capomar du sport comme vecteur
d'insertion c'est la philosophie de
l'association 974 action qui a mis en
place ce projet esprit Beach au indien
c'est un projet qui est donc soutenu par
le département de La Réunion à savoir
avec la mission de coopération
internationale et régional du
département donc on a le ministère de
l'Europe et les affaires étrangères qui
est partenaire de depuis cette année
2023 jusqu'à 2024 et on a aussi le
territoire de l'Ouest donc qui est
partenaire depuis l'année dernière
également donc on est sur un projet qui
est qui est de développer une activité
très accessible qui est le beach rugby
autant à Madagascar sur l'île
Saint-Marie autant sur l'île d'Anjouan
et autant à la
Réunion qui est une activité qui se veut
ludique accessible un short un ballon on
joue sur le sable le côté insulaire des
îles de ces
ond àesprit qu'onut don de plaisir de
joie en bord de mer s'amuser avec le
soleil l'ambiance la musique la culture
donc on est
sur sur le donc un développement sur
chaque île un événement pH sur chaque
île aussi de de concerné par le projet
et sur chaque événement une mobilité en
réciprocité de jeunes de La Réunion
d'Anjouan Comor et de saintmarie
Madagascar l'occasion pour les jeunes de
découvrir un sport mais aussi de les
sensibiliser au respect de la nature on
est beaucoup sur l'engagement et au fil
des semaines et des mois maintenant les
jeunes sont interpellés sur
l'environnement à savoir la
déforestation les dégâts que ça peut
faire et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
pour comment dire une alternative qu'on
pourrait trouver pour pas consommer le
charbon pour pas brûler le bois fa
savoir à sainmarie à Madagascar quand on
arriveon dit que le charbon faut faire
attention c'est quand même avec ça qui
se chauffe et avec ça qui mange l'esprit
Bich va donc au-delà du sport et permet
des échanges et des expériences uniques
à travers le Bich
rugby c'est c'est c'est très important
et tout les rencontres on rencontre de
nouvelles personnes de nouvelles en des
nouveaux horizons et en plus on peut
connaître les différents façons de vivre
qui n'est pas forcément pareil et donc
du coup échanger sur ça et et puis pour
du jeu bah de base je ne fais pas le
rugby mais quand je suis rentrée dans
l'association ben j'ai trouvé que
c'était quand même intéressant du coup
ben j'ai décidé de continuer la
délégation comorienne qui était
également invitée n'a pas pu venir faute
de visa c'est en tout cas la prochaine
destination de l'esprit Bich l'an
prochain h jeunes réunionnés se rendront
à
enjin